c'est une personne essentielle dans une
petite commune et je parle de petites
communes puisque les secrétaires de
mairie ce sont des personnes qui
travaillent dans les communes de moins
de 3500 habitants mais en réalité
beaucoup dans les communes de moins de
2000 habitants et c'est le binôme du
maire c'est la personne qui répond à
tout les demandes toutes les
sollicitations des administrés et des
élus elles font l'état civiles elles
s'occupent d'urbanisme elle s'occupe du
budget elle s'occupe du Bureau d'aide
sociale elle s'occupe de tout on appelle
les couteaux suisses des communes
[Musique]
des difficultés existent il faut y
remédier alors pour ce faire il s'agit
d'un premier temps de reconnaissance du
métier et ceci se passe par
l'inscription dans le Code général des
collectivités territoriales des
fonctions de secrétaire de mairie voilà
ça c'est important le fait d'inscrire
dans le Code des Collectivités
Territoriales ces fonctions induira de
fait une nouvelle bonification
indiciaire c'est-à-dire une prime donc
c'est aussi une valorisation en termes
de rémunération ensuite j'ai tenu à ce
qu'il y ait une formation obligatoire à
la prise de poste on sait qu'elles ont
des grosses difficultés pour s'absenter
pour être formés parce que elles sont
seules souvent dans un poste donc
personne pour les remplacer parce
qu'elles sont souvent isolées des lieux
de formation donc des difficultés de
déplacement donc elles partent très peu
en formation or elles ont besoin d'être
formées tout au long de leur carrière
mais particulièrement à la prise de
fonction pour être performante dès le
début de leur mission donc inscription
obligatoire instruction pardon d'une
formation obligatoire dans la première
de prise de poste ensuite j'ai souhaité
qu'elle puisse bénéficier d'une
promotion interne un petit peu accélérée
voilà c'est à dire que des agents de
catégorie C passent en catégorie B des
agents de catégories B passant catégorie
A par le biais de cette promotion
interne donc moi en réalité ce que je
souhaiterais vraiment à terme c'est que
les maires recrutent des agents de
catégories B en au poste de secrétaire
de mairie qu'il n'est pas la possibilité
de recruter en catégorie C et je pense
que ça c'est une vraie valorisation du
métier on reconnaît à ses agents que
l'émission qu'ils exercent sont de
catégories B pour moi c'est la
principale valorisation que l'on peut
leur accorder
[Musique]